[Applause]
James spins James drives off the class
it's good
poor blocked by James
and a foul before the shot attempt
divincenzo bumped him there in the
penalty so free throws
he's playing like a pope Bear right now
this movement transitions spin get to
his spot Elevate over to contest freight
train and then again the effort on the
other end of the floor this is a layup
for pool
LeBron James does not on my watch and
look who's in the house fight on young
man Ronnie James USC's own
and again first 13 minutes he didn't
take a shot he's doing all passing he's
got seven assists eight rebounds
and here's the MVP chance
that's come to fruition four times in
his careers play Thompson back in
he's not going to be able to Pace
himself and then win this series he's
going to have to give
the efforts that you were just raving
about Market back in transition to help
attacking constantly into the paint
posting
it's the free throws he's been hearing
in the locker room post game his
teammates making those goat noises I
could go that would be weird it's
actually pretty funny as Paul is fouled
with 159 remaining
if you enjoy when we're having breakfast
and they do it around you
I just can't imagine being a
professional basketball player and
walking into the